hello hello hello we're over a month
into this quarantine and it's a pretty
stressful time like it's stressful for
everybody not just us healthcare workers
there's all sorts of new challenges that
we're facing that we simply didn't
expect so I wanted to make a video where
I can help you get through this
difficult time as the best version of
yourself I want to give a huge thank you
to Nike for sponsoring this video where
I'm going to be giving you some
strategies to optimize both your
physical and mental health in order for
me to give you comprehensive advice on
self-care we have to talk about both the
mind and body in fact I don't like that
they're separate words it should be mind
body cuz they're so intimately connected
any change you make to your mental
health will show physical effects any
change he makes your physical health
will show mental effects first let's
focus up here the mindset that I want
you to have during quarantine when we're
generally not moving around much is on
movement I want you motivated and
excited to go for that run to do that
exercise regimen let's get you started
with these few tips make tech your
friend there's all sorts of meditation
and mindfulness apps that can help you
get motivated what I like to do is
listen to the Nike Run Club audio guided
runs they have athletes and motivational
speakers like coach Bennett to really
boost my mood and my performance at the
same time stay on routine for many of us
jobs give our day structure and with so
many people being out of work or their
work being disrupted it's very easy to
go to sleep at any time wake up at any
time of the day but that actually adds a
layer of chaos to your life that your
mind and body both don't like so create
a routine and stick to it plus you'll
make your life easier oh it's five
o'clock gotta exercise because that's
just what I do understand willpower too
many people assume they have to be
motivated in order to get an action
action proceeds willpower you need to
take that first step do the first
exercise class in order for you to get
some willpower for the next time doesn't
have to be anything huge just something
small that you can check off as a
success in order to refill the willpower
tank stay social physical distancing
does not mean social isolation humans
are social beings we crave that type of
next FaceTime a friend go on a Skype
meeting with all of your family members
to talk some drama go on a real date
take it seriously don't just get on a
couch in pajamas get a meal get all
dressed up celebrate human resilience
humans are great at bouncing back from
adversity and a pandemic like this is
the definition of adversity in fact what
we've seen with scientific research is
evidence for post-traumatic growth so
while most humans when they go through
something traumatic their baseline drops
and I think it bounced back to normal
once adversity ends but when
post-traumatic growth you actually see
this baseline drop off and then come up
even higher so we can come out of this
pandemic as better humans those who
appreciate the things we once took for
granted let's do that get physical folks
you got to keep your body in motion you
got to stay moving
I know it's hard now during a quarantine
when gyms are closed and perhaps running
outside isn't so safe you still have to
do it otherwise you're gonna develop
aches pains your moods gonna suffer
let's start with something I've fallen
in love with online exercise classes
courtesy of the Nike Training Club your
head hips and ankles should all be in a
nice straight line sit back into your
hips and lower yourself down so your
upper legs are parallel to the ground
stay relaxed and Child's Pose you have
to make do with what you have and I have
a stationary bike this is perfect for
getting a high intensity interval
workout it for those of you who don't
know an HIIT workout is one where you
alternate long periods of low intensity
exercise followed by short bursts of
high-intensity low intensity is slow low
effort high intensities like an all
outbursts for a short period of time and
trust me in like 20-30 minutes you can
get a solid workout in where you're
burning fat maintaining muscle cardio
strength training all in one and you
don't need a stationary bike for that
you could do it on a treadmill you could
even do it in your hallway
[Music]
everything I'm explaining to you is
about being adaptable leading into
uncertainty and making use with what you
have I know there's gonna be people out
there that are saying look Mike I
appreciate doing squats at home but I
need weights you make use of what you
have what do I have okay I'm obviously
joking don't use your dog you could use
other things this way like sandbags I
have a sandbag to hold down the C stand
and I have dog hair on the kettlebell
swings this is actually pretty heavy and
it's a good workout okay get it not
everyone has a sandbag almost everyone
has a book bag that you can load up with
heavy stuff kettlebell swings you see
what I'm saying that everyone needs
fancy gym equipment in order to get a
good workout it not a brethren even
though this is a quarantine we're in a
pandemic you still can have a good time
and stay fit at the end of the day I'm a
doctor and doctors write a lot of
prescriptions but prescriptions and all
medical treatments need to be
individualized so here's your
prescription a prescription for play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks Nike for sponsoring this video